[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le spectacle était au rendez-vous au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en yeline
pendant 2 jours les 9 et 10 décembre les
meilleurs spécialistes de BMX Freestyle
ont réalisé des figures dans l'aair
central de la future structure olympique
une grande première caravie les sportifs
alors c'était incroyable parce que Ben
faire ça ici dans un Vélodrome ben c'est
fou parce qu'il y a plein de monde
autour tout ça et c'est le centre du
cyclisme français donc c'est incroyable
c'est trop bien parce que ben il y a
tous les Grad autour la piste ben ça
rassemble tout le monde et c'est c'est
fou quoi c'était trop chouette d'être
ici au Vélodrome national de saquentin
en Evelin c'est vraiment un spot hyper
important pour nous parce que c'est là
où va y avoir la piste cet été pendant
les Jeux donc c'était un chouette clin
d'œil de pouvoir Raider ici pour ces
championnat de France le lieu est
complètement unique c'est une vraie
cathédrale du vélo en France donc trop
chouette de Raider ici plus de 90
sportifs de toute la France sont venus
sur ce rendez-vous les stars de la
discipline ont brillé laori Perez
remporte le titre de championne de
France chez les féminines et Anthony
jeanjan gagne chez les garçons c'est un
bon entraînement pour les compétitions
internationales ça me permet un peu dans
la période hivernale de de faire de r en
compétition avec des des trixs de de
haut niveau donc donc non je suis très
content au total plus de 2000 ont
assisté à cet événement 50% du public
venait des 12 communes de
l'agglomération de C ANBL honnêtement
les figures les trics les les
saut il y a un petit jeune là il a fait
une belle belle
prestationous a fait une petite chute à
la fin mais hnement cétait pas mal
cétait pas mal du coup nous on est à
côté en fait comme on aim bien les sport
extrême on est venu voir un peu ce qu'
en était ici c'était un super événement
organisé àqutin
Enor auid
dans c'est géni
ambi viment top les organisateurs
espèent cet événement en intérieur dans
les prochaines années le vélodrome de 50
an pour à nouveau accueillir le
rendez-vous